[音楽]
ます
こんにちは
[音楽]
弾みそうですいや今日だけはうちのショップを選んでください
僕いちごダーリン
声中で今日はハンといえばやはり一度凄く美味しい時期だと思うんですよ
で一番ってながら一口で食べるちょうどいいサイズじゃないですか
南国得るだろうなって
おったわけですよ攻めに今こちらに500個のイチゴがあります暇な方
数えてみてくださいそれで僕今すごいを投げて果たしてこの25歳の成人男性が本を
出すと
一度な勤めているのか今回検証していきたいとおもいます
5500坪あるんですけどもう全部は多分
いや物の空気では言いますよもう全部食い待って企画ように僕が何を食べるかを
ちょっと検証していきたいとおもいます
本当に限界まで良いと思いますでも出来ればおいしく食べたいんであれ味付けとが
いろんな工夫をしてって美味しく
限界まで麺を食べるかなってちょっと調べてみようと思いますえほんと最近ちょっと
織布構成すぎてまじで誰かこれおいしい新しい
ですごい楽しみです池記念すべき一個目ですいただきます
[音楽]
うめぇ
ただ一言と甘くて美味しいんですよねなんか全然食べやすい
スイーツ感覚で食べれるまあどんどん行きましょう
持って行った
ん
ij 3足食べました
うん
ねぇ短冊なっても全然まだおいしい余裕があるかわいい
だめっちゃウェルズ氏の800倍楽です
voodoo
はいぐずって食べましたちょっと規制室
やばいなやってるいけると思うんですけどまあしいて言うならちょっと水分がすごい
ですね
みずみずしくて美味しいです
美味しいです
あああああ
美味しいですどんだけじゃさあ
なぜここに来てやってっ
もうすごい多いなあこれやばい覆えばやいきます
ん
me
goo
わっ
散歩飛びましたーーー
俺どんどん食べ方してんだろう
じゃない私告ってみての感想はもうお腹た2分ですねもうちょっと普通に食べてみます
[音楽]
いまいちは120個飛びました
全然までいけるんですけどちょっともう味を帰っていかないと持ちツインでここから4
な味付けを加えていきます
まずはこれホイップクリームこれも税制にイチゴにホイップ国も欠けたらお誕生日
ケーキになるんじゃねえかなとさんもこれでもバス停契機になっちゃう末れないです
からね
上
これでめちゃくちゃ美味しかったら嬉しいです
[音楽]
ん
生クリームもおいしいね家がおいしいんですけど生クリームの美味しい
今の俺はちょっと生回目でもうちょい攻めてみますむしろこれなんか
これでも生クリーム状を作ってあってここに一方向ディップしていくって作成にし
ましょうか
[音楽]
me
パッ
相撲
極めてもつっついな根本的な部分は何も変わってません
次ははい今ねーずミルクちょっと大根が水かけて食べるイメージがあるんで
何度これでしなければ最高かなと思います
普通 new はそうだなとだけすっ
だじゃあ今の俺には効果がねぇ次長尾寺そうなチョコレートカップを買ってきました
苺とチョコはもう撮っても切り離せない関係なのでちょっと一部の絶命の
コラボレーションでこれを突破していきたいとおもいます
やります
メジャーだめだめだめだたぶんこれはもう味付けどうこうの問題じゃなく
僕がそもそももう食べれないという問題かもしれませんただいま133戸
もうちょっと頑張っています
150個食べました
やばいいやおいしいの分かって美味しいんだけどだけで実しね
と言えるん誰がいい
美味しい案件だった全然混ぜております
ame
分
まいっもう部類はいというわけで ok でも結構
訪ね全力を尽くして成人男性25歳が食べれる15乗り方はだいたい
170個ぐらいかなと思いました結構食って100個ぐらいでサーブ終わると思ったん
ですけど一番時代美味しかったのもあったんですけど
170戸マネーめりました
ちょっとこれのこそもったいないので今からスタッフで美味しく頂こうと思います皆4
を
[音楽]
はいというわけで無事次号奴みんなで食べ終わりました
男4人がかりで食べたんですけど4人でを500校は相当きつかったです
僕はアナとち餅を食べて結局最終的には200円な何個
イチゴを食べてしまいましたいや200個超えたらなかなかすごいと思いますよ
よくやばいんですけどっ
愛という技ですね今回なんで僕こんなたくさん一部を食べたかと言いますと
ちょっとある漫画に葉張りましてこちら空腹の夕食っていう漫画があるんですよ
結構出てるんですけどこれでつい最近女子高生になった女の子のお話なんですけども
なんかめちゃくちゃ食べるのが好きな女の子で
でこうなんかすごい青春的な物語なんですけども
なんかそこにすごい食べ物も見るだけでメッツ離れるような漫画ですごい青春っぽい
内容があったりしてて気づいたらめちゃくちゃ読んじゃってました
おすすめなんでぜひ読んでみてくださいで今度ジョイ何するかと言いますと全作品全話
無料で見れますそしてネット全作品フルから
ベニーねあとか強みなんですよこうで普通にそう
キスだけでどんどん見ていけるんですごい音ストレスでスマホでも真ん中楽しむことが
できます
じゃあもうちょっと見るだけでもいろんなマンガがもうありますね
こ2のランキングとかもあります漫画ってなんか更新頻度があるじゃないですか
なんか毎週新しい話が出るとかあると思うんですけどもなんと現在ですねちょいの一部
の漫画で毎日更新キャンペーンを実施しております
やめられねえぜさらに少女座は譲っていう漫画ではプレゼントキャンペーンもやってる
みたいなので
て
に参加してくださいとしては沿いのアプリと web ページで確認してみてください
いやほんとで空腹の夕食いいですよネクソンで高級料理とが出てくるわけじゃないん
ですけど
家庭的な料理とかをめちゃくちゃ美味しそうにたくさん食べるんで女子校生感があって
恐れ方です動画概要欄からダウンロードできますのでぜひ皆さんのいろんな漫画選んで
みてください
じゃ
た
me
ああああああ
あっはぁ